So god. Wins.
And i do more with jackson. So why.
Double l i e. Jackson normal.
Like ok i came to australia.
Oh i'm julie jackson
and i came to australia in 1973
after the equerries festival.
I heard about aquarius. When i was
living in the himalayas in katmandu.
Writing long
and passionate letters to my sweetheart
who was in australia at the time.
We had met in hong kong
and i was taking a very long time
to return to western civilization.
I spent a year in kathmandu.
Went to england
and whilst i was i was an england he
sent me to get to come to australia.
So it was.
An offer i wasn't unable to refuse.
I arrived in australia in august
and came up to nimbin about 10 days later
and my arrival in australia been.
A little disappointing. The love
story wasn't quite the love story.
I thought it was and.
It was very obvious that we weren't
going to live happily ever after. So.
When i was coming.
We were coming through from poland get out
having met my possible future in-laws.
I came down to nimbin. And
it was on the road to u.k.
that I was struck by this
overwhelming knowing
that this is where i was supposed to be
living this is where i supposed to be.
The idea of nimbin and and. Aquarius
was already very appealing to me.
I had quit my job in hong kong as a
very jet set a fashion designer living.
Fully. And fast around the world.
And i felt that i needed
to make more my life
and having seen what was
happening in the world.
And i believe there was another way
of doing things the commercialism
and selfishness that i experienced. In
its own head in a stick way wasn't.
What i wanted to do so.
Nor was living in sydney and
being a playwrights write life.
What i wanted to do either so.
There was this knowledge that that i had
that nimbin was well i really should be
but i had no idea how or what was going
to happen i went back to sydney and.
Somehow i met the right people
and i ended up coming up
to nimbin for the first.
Countable tribal meeting which would
have been about september i think.
With a very beautiful man called poet called
will tetley who i don't know where he
is in the world now and i got the train.
And was hitching from.
Lismore to nimbin
and was picked up by caroline norman who
were to go on to be very important in my
life. When my children's lives.
Carol was the midwife who
set up birth and beyond
and norman her partner
was a great healer and.
There i was in nimbin. And with
nowhere to go nowhere to stay.
I didn't know anybody at that
will who had his own things to do
and an intention to go to the first time
double trouble meeting i had a job by the
way and to repay my rose to us.
We've had back for my ticket.
To australia and.
I never been in those days
was very small was very warm
and very friendly and.
Anybody new in town was immediately
noticeable and immediately people would come
and welcome you and talk to them
and so on and it so happened
that this beautiful blue
eyed dark eyelash young man
sat down beside me inside.
Started talking to me and
introduced himself as mark
and i said do you know where i can stay
and he said oh well we've got a bails you
could come and stand the bells. At all.
Toby so. I'll toby's from. Lord of
the rings i think or something.
And all these wonderful
names of places that were
that were developed in those days
and as true romance would have it.
Mark who i renamed marcus
and i fell in love and.
Had three babies and got married
at some stage and. Then.
Parted at some stage and remained
very good friends over the years.
About babies and the like
is it and second it's a.
Very green and rich and for
kundera it's mel's fertile.
Things grow overnight you can
sit and watch things grow.
And the feeling in in the 70s certainly
within my generation was i guess we were.
Obviously young and of childbearing age
and there was a great hope
great optimism for the future
that we wanted to make things different.
And part of making things different is
creating the generation to to carry
that on and. A desire
to do it differently.
Many many of us had had
experience childhoods
that were maybe not as helpful as could be
that were were pressured by materialism
which we all benefited from.
But there was that
that pendulum looking back now with
the wisdom of age you know there was
that pendulum of wanting to reject all of
that materialism which we saw was leading
us down a fairly devastating path as we
experiencing now. So.
Yeah to to to make families to
create and create a new society
and part of creating a new society
is creating new life and.
So and it's such a joyful process.
I mean for me having babies was
one of the most amazing joyful
experiences that ever ever had in my
life so i you know i love having babies.
I love being pregnant. And.
And and i love the nurturing.
You know it's it was.
It was something that that had
always been part of my nature
but it really came into its
full and. No babies and and.
Expressed itself in me looking
after everybody else's babies too.
And i became a wet nurse
and was an official wet
nurse and. I had three.
Three babies long term for four for periods
of time one for three months i think
i fed ruby. And my son.
I moved into the house.
With ruby parents and and nurse
to us. A mother was ill and.
And to what my own children with me
i had three by then and. All told.
That the rough tally is around 200 babies.
That i breastfed over the years
and it was it was natural.
It was a natural thing to do the tween the
mothers who we were very close friends
and we if there was for me if there
was a baby that was crying or a mama
that was tired. It was so easy and very
simple for me to just nurse the baby.
And maybe take take that take it a baby
for a night to get their mother rest.
People did the same thing for me
to it wasn't a one way street
and it was part of the tribal feeling
that we experienced in those days
and so now.
Sort of 17 18 years later i'm meeting.
Many of my mighty babies as as
as as i think of them. You know.
At dances and clubs and parties and
and seeing them growing up and even.
I'm sort of a titty granny now.
One of one of the children.
What i looked after recently had a baby
and i don't know how many are they've
all scattered to the four winds
and in many cases but a lot of them are
still around and that their precious
and beautiful young people
and i have very good connections with many
of them still is coming together mothers
and raising that.
It was one that was one aspect of it.
Yes the desire to do it differently.
The desire for different experiences
the the the the longing to move away
from the the mechanical and
impersonal and come to know
that giving birth is a natural thing it's
not not not an illness it didn't need to
be hospitalized. I guess it was it
was a step further step beyond.
The the the lib oil method that was
already very popular in europe
and i think probably in australia.
In england the home birth was was a fairly
normal sort of thing to have my sisters
were both born at home and i was
presence for those births and
that with their then and
then their thirties.
So you know that that. You had that.
That was one aspect of the hunger and the
closeness and support support network
that was built up between the women.
Was very important not only was
that the sort of the actually
having a baby at home important but
but the support afterwards which which
varied and some cases it was full on and
and wonderful and
and there's in all of those things
sometimes it missed the mark
and it wasn't perhaps as good as it
could have been and that we you know.
We did beautiful things and it was you
know again those bonds that were set up
and nosed those days
are still very strong.
And as the children grew up
and as we grew up as women.
You know as we grew up and changed and.
Experiences changed our needs changed.
You know we developed in two to two
women who wanted. Something else and.
Needed to grow and.
The we had the women's group
which was a very strong
and dynamic and exciting
time for a lot of us
and was a shift in many many
years of women's lives where.
I'm trying to remember
i'm dreadful on dates.
It would have been. Late 70s.
It would have been someone in the
late in the 70s. It was like.
In the late 70s the women's group
started we were generally met in
blue knob round blue knob area there was i
think there was other groups of women as
well. Meeting and in the area. The one
that i was involved in matters blown up.
Once a week and there was probably
up to about 12 women coming together
and we would have have.
That idea set agendas on some
nights themes telling us to be
exploring options discussing things it
wasn't an incredibly angry sort of a group
of women it was more a discovering
supportive nurturing group of women.
You know there's the ideas of women's
groups being sort of bunches of howard
and sort of bitching about their menfolk
and things and it wasn't like that too.
There was there was the old
bitch of course but. You know.
They're having their turn and. Yes.
Yes.
They became a tribal event
because they weren't confined to
the birth the birth at home
became a tribal event because
they were not confined to to
medical personnel being present
or the official personnel being pleasant.
No just immediate family members so.
At some births there would be maybe a dozen
people around the place people to to
cook people to to look after other children
people to look after the other people's
children and and general supporters
there was and people came
and went you know if it was a long
birth of people would be coming coming
and going and there was a lot of interest.
You know we the birth and beyond.
Group met every tuesday and
there was prenatal classes and
and post natal classes and so on that
and meetings of women to to support
and fathers to the fathers because you know
you know were very actively involved in
the whole process and the caring
of the children as well i think
that that's something but that
isn't isn't recognized and i think
that a lot of nimbin dads
have done a very good job.
You know it's it's perhaps
a difficult one to sort of
to single out isn't it wonderful
that men are involved in children
but tradition is such that
that men are not involved in child rearing
women you know have traditionally done
that and sometimes that's been
something we've kept to ourselves.
I know that for me. That
was probably an issue and
and so yeah the menfolk have
played a part as well as being
caught up in the more
traditional roles of how has.
Building and and so on
and the women have also been involved
us first there in the house building
and so on.
Perhaps i didn't. Absolutely.
I mean although i was a home birth
helper myself i had my three children in
hospital. The first one was
because she was a breech baby.
No she wasn't she was before the birth.
The first one was my first child
was born in hospital because
that the home birth movement was.
Very young at that stage
and i think only one baby had been
born at home in the area then
and i didn't feel confident enough it was
later on that i got involved. Really.
Fully my second child was born in
hospital because she was a breech baby
and the third one there. We're
other complications in his birth.
So they were they were
all born in the hospital
but it was a very very positive
experience. Emily was the first baby.
Hippie baby to be born
in lismore base hospital
and they were very supportive i
mean we still i still had to go out
and the go some of the
indignities like shaving and.
An animals which don't even
happen in normal births now
but they allowed me to do a lot
of the other things that i wanted
and even to the point of letting me take
the centre home which they they found.
You know the placenta was wrapped up
in and a lovely purple plastic bag and
and kept in the refrigerator
until i went home
and they let me out the next day you know
with a few sort of and worried looks.
So from from that to when will was
born. It was it was beautiful.
You know it was just really beautiful.
Carol and norman with me i had
another friend there. His father.
On the birth was done in exactly the
way that i wanted to to do it out.
You know i couldn't have asked for better
in that sort of environment and and
and after the birth we were left alone
and he was whisked off to be bathed
and measured and weighed and
faster and they were so i think
that the influence of the home birth
movement in the hospitals has been has been
good as you know and there were
some fears and difficult things
but i think it's been overall
i think it's been good
and in cairo called they have a birthing
center which is is the next step from
having a home birth sort of in
between having a home birth and
and a hospital birth. So you know
it's been influential and and i think
that it it it in that
positive and supportive.
Generally approach
that the hospital has makes it easier for
women who are perhaps in a risky group to
feel comfortable about having
their babies in the hospital as.
Water births and things like that.
I've not been present in a water
birth i know a number of babies
that have been born in water birth
and i've seen the movies and so on.
It seems wonderful and and hospitals
around the place also provide
that service to and and
doctors are involved in it.
I think that it's it's it just off that
now we it's not just either hospital
or a dangerous but at homeless or so
and you know have see the see the
options of all you were having.
The more options recently there's been
a backlash as we always experience
and in change and i believe that.
You know that then non-accredited
lay midwives are not allowed to.
I deliver babies at home
and this is i think a
very retrograde step.
And as.
Was.
Traditional. I think i think it's again
about that pendulum. It's about.
I think what had happened in the
60s the 50s and 60s postwar was
that they'd been
that great swing to too far to
mod cons to materialism too to.
Getting away from from the
the spirit and community
and so it was a very very fast
swing on the pendulum and
and sometimes you have to to swing
the pendulum right the other way.
You know to show all of
that stuff away so that so.
To then come back to some kind of balance
to find out to sort out what is necessary
and what isn't necessary to
to to find out. You know.
A balance and and sure you know i
think there was there was a you know.
I would never want to be scrubbing
and washing nappies in a in a in a
copper again even if i was young
and starting out you know it was it's.
It was hard work and particularly for
the women. It was very very hard work.
I think that we you know.
The work wasn't the time often
to do a lot of the things that.
That would have been good to do. I mean.
I would always you know give over. Housework
in favor of playing with my children.
So i always lived in a
fairly chaotic house but
when you have to chop the
wood to cook the food
when you have to cut the
water to do those things
when you have to dig the
garden to get the the food.
It's it's very hard work and yet
you don't need all the mod..
Once and things that are happening you
don't need all the fast foods and things
and that the chemicals and.
And so on that it that are contributing
to this duction of the planet either.
So it's finding
that balance.
What are my fondest memories my
fondest memories of picnics.
We had wonderful techniques picnics and
community gatherings and the dances.
We we put on the birth
and beyond bullseye
wonderful the folk club.
The comings together of the community.
Very very special memories and.
And the smells the night. The rain.
When it's been sunny not the rain after
it's rained for three months. And.
Yeah that hope that the people and
the coming together the people
and the coming together
of many different people.
Many of the the original settlers the
original people who lived in the main area
are very very dear friends
of mine now. Who.
I probably see more than a lot of the other
people who've been through nimbin over
the years. So.
Nimbin as a place for as a learning
ground as a wonderful learning ground a
wonderful growing time. And it's got its
pain as well you know there's been this.
There's been difficult time. Punk.
There's been difficult times.
You know that the survival.
In the eighties.
You know. The growing apart
of my my husband and i.
You know knowing that that this
idyllic life isn't going to to go on.
I think maybe we we played
a lot as children too.
You know as we played with our children.
So there was a a certain. Unreality there.
That was very real in the dirt and
in the earth and in the being but.
Even now i think that i was saying
to somebody today that the lifestyle
that we have on the north coast
here. Is very special you know.
And it's not the way a
lot of the world lives.
It's not the way that that even the
people that i meet in my work life.
And. I think we need to bear that
in mind as well you know that.
There's a there's a lot of despair
and a lot of pain in the world
and we're very fortunate. I don't know.
And i think it was a little bit childish.
I think that. That.
Naivete. Was an important part of
the growing up. As an infant is a.
An important part of the exploration
that i think nimbin is going through
and was going through.
To everything has a
duality and so that that
that that childishness was part of
that the oldness of knowing that
that things were not going right. The
wisdom that things were not going right.
So again to swing to to that absolute.
Simplicity. Was it was an important part.
If it hadn't happened it wouldn't have
you wouldn't have gone the whole way.
It's like you've got to push the edge and.
And with all of that with
that so-called lack of responsibility i
mean it's all a matter of perception really
i mean i think perhaps it was a very
responsible thing to do is a very responsible
thing to do to say hey no this.
This isn't going the right way.
We've got to stop this
greed and destruction
and materialistic approach to things
we've got to find community again
and get back to to the
important things. And.
It was very very idealistic
but unless you have.
Something that's very idealistic
unless you should high.
You're not going to you're not
going to going to get very far.
So so.
I think that it's it is important
to to have that that that openness
and simplicity and call it naivete and
and with that then there's room to grow
and then there's room to grow up.
If you if you if you call it that.
To take responsibility and to see that the
shadow side of things. Then pins got it.
Shadow side now it's acceptance has
has has on one side has led to
abuse people who abuse that
acceptance. It's it's.
Dropping of modern modernity
and mod cons has led to to a lot
of people getting very tired
and a lot of people having
to live very hard lives.
The rejecting of the sort of
work and paid work for for.
Supporting that capitalistic and
materialistic society that that was part.
Out of
that has led to to perhaps an
inability to to to see other options
for doing things.
And that in this in turn is led to in some
cases lack of self-esteem and so on so.
And so.
And at the same time we've got the rainbow
power company we've got children who are
flexible and broad thinking
and caring. We've got.
A way of of approaching things
that is very different with the the home
birth movement the negotiation skills.
Community living checking it out you
know we can people can write in theory.
About living in community
and things were people in the nimbin area
in the north coast area because nimbin
isn't just nimbin it's it's the north
coast and beyond and beyond and beyond.
So people are actually doing it and have
been doing it for a long long time.
You know buddy phones been going for a
long time tentacles been going for a long
time and so on and so forth.
I think the things don't
have to be. You know.
Set in black and white.
Oh no no no i mean it's it's it's.
There's for me there's there's absolutely
no sense of failure. I think that.
I mean if you if you take the approach to
life which i have which is nothing is for
no reason that that every situation.
Has a positive side and a negative side.
Every cloud has a silver lining.
So you know
that the growing of nimbin the developing
of nimbin the moving on from from the
original aquarius dream. It's perfect.
You know it's it's it's there is
there is pain and there is there is.
Some some really negative things
that that could be focused on
and there were there and there
are the positive things
and if you see it on a long term basis if
you see it in them in the continuum of
ages. It's just a my new little thing
you know and the effects of it are huge
and so. If you. You know.
I refuse to get caught
up in any breast beating
and angst about it you know it's
it is what is and and it's growing
and people are still talking about it.
People are still talking about a
close 20 years on that's you know
and people you know young
people are. Still holders.
Or develop those ideals. And and the older
people who've been involved in aquarius.
The division changes but. Once
an aquarian always an aquarium.
You know i wasn't even
there for the festival.
You know.
Frivolous.
What is no world.
I. Right.
Well that they had their head in
there's a move of nimbin is. Is good.